pas de longues files d'attentes pas de
touristes seuls quelques habitués qu'ils
arrêtent pour commander chez schwarz le
chiffre d'affaires a fondu de 80 pour ça
neuf employés sont toujours en poste
une quarantaine d'autres ont été mises à
pied ouvert depuis 1928 le célèbre
restaurant montréalais est lui aussi
durement touché
on est ouvert juste pour payer les
factures et ip le staff c'est plus une
série où nos clients que que fed alors
on ne fait pas d'argent menace avant la
crise 275 mille personnes travaillaient
dans la restauration au québec
ils ne sont plus que cent mille les
pertes d'exploitation se chiffre en
milliards de dollars
en ce moment les restaurateurs sont dans
le noir
il ignore quand ils pourront rouvrir
leur salle à manger ou encore leur
terrasse comme ici au jardin nelson
chaque jour qui passe fait grimper les
certitudes au restaurant habituellement
ouvert d'avril à octobre
faut bien comprendre que donald qu'on ne
puisse pas ouvrir avant le mois d'août
barovier de rayer de la carte la saison
20 cabines de verre prise de température
panneaux qui sépare les convives
équipements de protection pour le
personnel toutes sortes de mesures ont
été mises en place pour relancer la
restauration dans les pays qui ont
amorcé leur déconfinement à vilnius en
lituanie
on a décidé de transformer les espaces
publics en terrasse pour aider les
restaurateurs à servir les clients tout
en respectant la distanciation physique
au québec l'industrie mise aussi sur ce
genre d'initiative la rue le 3-3 les
terrains de stationnement pour être
utilisée pour permettre à ce moment-là
d'accueillir un peu plus de clients
ça sera la seule façon pour nous d'aller
chercher peut-être des des revenus qui
vont être très réduits disons le à
werder une portion de la rue wellington
sera transformée en rue piétonnière cet
été l'arrondissement envisage de laisser
plus de place aux terrasses comme on le
fait habituellement sur la rue
sainte-catherine dans le quartier gai
mais une grande question demeure les
clients sont ils au rendez vous la
restauration comme à la connaissez je
pense que c'est terminé
comme de nombreux établissements le
pastaga s'est rapidement tournée vers
les livraisons et les commandes pour
emporter après la fermeture de sa salle
à manger
une tendance qui est là pour rester
selon le chef martin juneau
je pense que les gens ont plus envie de
vivre cette proximité lui qui pouvait
avoir dans un restaurant parce que de
faire servir par un serveur ben c'est
sûr qu'il y est proche de toi it annonce
les plats ils s'approchent pour remplir
ton nom ton vin pour ta porte et à
nourriture et c'est justement cette
proximité qui attire normalement les
clients chez helicopter
on va se concentrer sur les plats à
emporter et on va laisser la salle à
manger fermé s'il est impossible de
créer une ambiance chaleureuse site de
me savoir sont obligés d'avoir un masque
d'avant des gains de servir la
nourriture dans des plages de table j'ai
vu des choses comme ceux annoncés donc
je pense pas qu'ils vont semer quelque
chose moi vouloir établir ici je sais
pas je trouve ça un peu agressif l'un
d'avoir si peu vite dans ta face quand
et où d'avoir un moment agréable de
détente au leicester c'est ce que pense
aussi les djs termine elle qui adore
fréquenter les restaurants va savourer
l'état des chefs dans le confort de sa
maison
on n'est jamais vu ça avant alors si
c'est encore une côté positif dans tout
ça c'est de voir qu'on peut amener ces
grands restaurants chez nous pour
l'instant est de garder le contact avec
les restaurateurs qu'ils ont besoin de
nous le problème c'est que les
restaurateurs auront de la difficulté à
demeurer rentable s'ils ne remplissent
pas leur salle à manger la vérité sic on
dépense pas plus au restaurant lors
soirée entre amis entre amoureux avec un
apéro une entrée un plat un dessert un
digestif d'une bouteille que si on vient
d'implanter carte avec la moyenne par
client est beaucoup plus basse congé de
taxes municipales aide aux loyers
pouvoir vendre de l'alcool sans
nourriture les restaurateurs pense que
plusieurs mesures devront être mises en
place pour qu'ils puissent garder la
tête hors de l'eau ici olivier vachon
radio canada montréal